What we've got in here is liquid nitrogen.
Nitrogen from the air, normally gaseous
at this temperature and pressure,
but here it's been condensed,
and for it to remain condensed
it has to be very very cold,
so the liquid inside here
is an astonishing
minus 196 degrees Celsius
or cooler.
So, that cold, no-one in their right mind
would pour this on their hand...
So what's happening here
is the Leidenfrost effect,
named Johann Leidenfrost,
who wrote the paper in 1756
describing how when liquids boil,
a gaseous barrier
between the liquid and the surface that
they're boiling on
can act as a thermal barrier,
protecting, if you like,
my hand from the
extreme cold of the liquid.
So the key thing is that there's
a big temperature difference
between the liquid
and the surface that it's on.
Here we've got a very very cold liquid
on a room-temperature surface.
We can also do
the same sort of demonstration
with a room temperature liquid
on a very very hot surface,
like a hot plate.
So the surface right now
is measuring about 37 or 38 degrees.
if we squeeze some water onto it,
well nothing much happens
because it hasn't reached its boiling point.
And now we are at 100 degrees Celsius and clearly the water is boiling
on the surface.
Now it's reading 200 I'm going to pour the liquid on, the water on.
We can see droplets of water elevated
It's getting a bit steamy in here!
So we now have the Leidenfrost effect and what's happening
is that the second that the water touches the hot plate
it boils instantly and the gas coming out at the bottom elevates the droplet.
and is acting as a thermal barrier
preventing any further transfer of heat from the plate onto the liquid.
So it just seems to hover there and go on indefinitely.
Or it would if it just didn't roll off like that.
Similarly the surface of this desk is so much hotter than this nitrogen
exactly the same thing happens here.
Who cares?
Designers of boilers and kettles.
In the 1800s, of course steam was king
And even today the Leidenfrost effect
can be a bit of a curse when you're designing these kettles
which contain a heating element and if you heat the
water and the steam gathers around the element that will act as a
thermal insulator and if you're just heating the
steam around the element that's inefficient.
You might think we people are doing demonstrations with liquid nitrogen
they would be wearing these
sort of gloves all the time to protect themselves.
But actually the Leidenfrost effect protects you pretty well.
As long as you're not holding something for a long period of time that's very cold.
And you can imagine the situation where the nitrogen gets stuck down here.
Held against your skin and that would lead to the severe frostbite situation.
So goodbye gloves, hello leidenfrost.
you